All right, welcome everyone. As I have
promised you before, today we are going
to conduct a mock interview. Um, it will
be a algo session with my friend Anna
who uh has worked at GitHub and who is
right now senior software engineer in
working on infrastructure interesting
exciting stuff. I will leave some of the
links about the Anna. So she's doing
articles in Substack. So please go and
subscribe. She's doing a lot of uh great
articles related to interview experience
uh specifically behavioral interview and
stuff like that. So now Anna please
introduce yourself.
>> Thank you so much Andre. Uh also do want
to give you a huge shout out because you
were the person who helped me get my
current job. You helped me a lot with
system design and this is how we met.
And yeah, hi everybody. My name is Anna.
I was looking for a job over the last
year. It was pretty bumpy. Uh but
fortunately I did get a job and now I'm
a senior engineer. Uh I work on back end
and infra side of things and I'm excited
to do this mock because I want Andre to
also get a great job.
>> Yep.
>> As soon as possible. So we're gonna get
going and um we will share the feedback
afterwards.
>> Sure.
Uh, okay. Andre, I see you in the dock.
And I guess I'm gonna start with one
problem and then just so you know, we
will also have another problem if you
get through this quickly. But uh, let me
start with just explaining to you what
is the problem that I'd like to solve
with you. I kind of mostly just want to
hear how you think and how you approach
this problem. Again, I will explain this
to you. So imagine you have a number.
For example, I give you a number 9973
and you can swap two digits only once
and I ask you that you return me the
highest the maximum integer we can get
from this number. So if you look at this
number it is already the max right it
cannot get higher than this. We couldn't
make it 37 or we couldn't make it if we
were to put for example 7 93 that
doesn't get higher right so here we
don't need to get a swap so you can just
return me this number is however if I
give you a number for example 2836
uh can you give me the maximum number we
could get from here if we swap only two
digits just once do you think will be
the max number from this
Well, probably I would say we have to
swap first two digits, right?
This will give us the largest we can do.
No.
>> Yes, it's correct. Again, we could have
done it for example. Sorry, I will just
put it right here. Again, this is not
correct, but we the largest number we
could have gotten would be 86
um 32. However, if you notice here, we
have to swap them more than once, right?
We have to swap the first and the third
and then the third and the zero, right?
So, you're correct. The largest number
we can get from here is 8236.
And I just want to kind of see how you
think we can get there. And remember,
all I'm asking you is just that you
return this maximum number and you're
allowed to swap two digits at most once.
>> All right. All right. I see. I see. So
um the fact that we need to swap only
once uh simplifies the problem a lot to
be honest.
>> Um so my initial intuition would be
probably
um to start from left to right.
>> Mhm.
>> And as we can see um in case we are
going and we seeing numbers that are
same or lower than we have previously
from left to right we cannot do
anything. So essentially if we start
from left and we see any number that is
larger than current one we want to swap
them. Why the left and why we come from
left why we go from left to right is
because leftmost digits are uh
contributing the most uh to the size of
the integer essentially.
>> Uh so yeah I'm thinking right now that
uh what can be the other can it be like
this?
What if we have I'm just thinking about
more examples. What if we have this
case? [snorts]
>> Mhm.
>> In this case, I don't think we want to
swap with the first largest. Right. So,
probably this situation fails here
>> because we would if we would swap the
first one here, we would have 3286.
But probably the best number here would
be 8236,
I guess.
>> Yep.
>> No, no, no. 83
26 because we would swap 8 and two.
Yeah. 8 2 83. Yes. Yes. 8326. So
probably this is the largest number.
So it seems like from left to right we
should just go through the number and
find the largest one to the left that we
can find. And if we did find it [snorts]
then
Uh yes yes yes yes yes. Then we should
swap it. But apparently we might have
case that we don't want to swap the
leftmost but we might have case like
that for example.
>> Mhm.
>> And in this case we also sort of want to
yeah we should still
we should still swap eight and two right
here.
>> Yep. This would be the correct answer in
this case.
>> Do I get it right?
>> Uh yeah, that's correct. Yes, you can
only swap once.
>> Okay. [snorts] Okay. Okay. Okay. So,
yes, in this case, yeah, let me think.
Let me think.
Um
well to go from left to right we
probably will need to either reverse the
number so we can cut it mathematically
or we can go and change it to string or
array. Uh how do you feel about that? Is
it okay?
>> Yeah that's totally fine you can do
that. Y
>> okay so let's say we have this and we
can easily operate on the on the array.
[snorts]
>> And now what can be the algo here? Um
it bit feels like monotonic stack to
some extent but not quite sure yet.
So let's see we go nine and we see two.
We don't want to swap with two we
continue.
Yeah. And I think in case we don't want
to swap with two
current number should be changed to two
then. Yeah. Let me try to to to see can
we do it with monotonic stack in
general. So if we just try uh to put it
into the stack we see
two which is bigger than nine. So we
putting two here and then we are 38
up until we find six.
Yeah.
No, probably it's not that it's it
shouldn't be the way.
All right.
Yeah, definitely the the approach should
be that we should find something bigger
on the right side than we have on the
left side. The only thing I I just still
couldn't figure out yet
>> is how to proceed with this case that we
might have uh already biggest digit on
the left.
>> Mhm.
>> So in this case
[snorts]
uh well
why don't you actually go through just a
basic case? What if you go through the
case where the largest digit is to the
to the left of you? So how would you go
through that? Just take this case and
then we can talk about the case if the
largest digits is the first digit. How
would you approach this because you kind
of had the right idea.
>> Yeah. So in this case if we are sure the
largest uh number on the right which we
can be sure through many things
in this case we need just to find the
largest on the right. So essentially
maximum on the right part [snorts]
find first value largest value and
largest index and then just swap them
and it will be it. I guess it should
work. So given the case
uh the tricky case was which one this
was the tricky case that we have two we
have three and we have eight and then
let's say one
>> so in this case we don't want to swap
with first largest so instead we would
just keep I don't know we can save in
some data structure like what is the
maximum number for this range let's say
>> mhm
>> and for this range it will be eight I
will find the index of eight and Then I
would just swap to an eight and that
would be it.
>> Uh
does it sound good as a as a idea
itself?
>> I honestly think this is the idea. I
kind of want to talk to you. This is the
working idea. We can talk a little bit
about the case when the largest number
comes first. But tell me do you think
what's will be like the runtime space
complexity of this approach?
>> Yeah, it should be linear. uh for this
case should be linear because in ON we
would store maximum number for
particular uh suffix
>> in O that's for sure
>> and then uh
given this number even if we have the
largest on the left side already and we
would need to proceed one by one
>> still due to suffix uh we would have it
linear time and for space complexity it
will be O1 as well.
>> Mhm. Uh not sure we can do better here
honestly for now. Maybe we can. Um
>> I think it's an optimal solution like
honestly of N is as good as it's going
to get because we have to touch every
digit.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Makes sense. Makes sense.
So now let's consider the case of um
having the largest one on the left
already and then we should kind of
proceed.
>> Uh so let me try to visualize what I
would have in my um maximum suffix. So
probably we would get maximum suffix. So
constant time to resolve maximum number
for from particular index till the end.
Mhm.
>> Uh so let me draw yeah let me add this
as indices
and then
the suffix map which is going to be
yeah whatever now now it's suffix map so
it's index it's number
>> and this is suffix map so we would start
with four this going to be four this
going to be four oh sorry what four I'm
I'm checking the indices values so this
going to be six this going to be eight
so far then we're going to have eight
again because this is the largest eight
again and then nine in the end so this
is going to be kind of maximum suffix
>> uh that we see so far
>> and I think we can try to proceed from
left to right so let's say we have
converted it to array
>> start from the left index and if current
value is equal to maximum suffix we kind
of skip it and continue and then we see
that current value is less then maximum
suffix and we swap it straight away.
>> That's it. The only thing uh in order to
swap uh pretty quickly we need we cannot
do string. So we should do array
probably for swapping and we need to
maintain the index of this maximum
number as well. Uh
so how would I maintain? Um yeah and for
that I need actually start asking
questions about input and constraints.
So first one uh are the digits unique or
no?
>> Are they not unique?
>> They're not unique.
Okay. Uh
okay, that makes sense. That makes
sense. Uh then second question, can we
get integer overload because or
overflow? Sorry, overflow.
>> Assume no. The largest number you can
have is 10 to the^ of eight. Um but
assume like don't be concerned with
overload.
>> Okay. Okay. So this will be my suffix
map. And in this case uh since we might
have duplicates what we want to maintain
is the first index of the value that we
search for example. If we got eight as a
maximum and we have two eights here
probably or no maybe we want the last.
So comparing if you have this case uh
probably I guess that this would be
lower than
sorry then this one right?
Yes. So this number is larger than this
one. So it means we need to maintain the
first occurrence of this particular
value. That's it. And for that
>> uh for that I can add map. Uh so let's
say I'm going to have in map that would
store the following. It would store
value to first index essentially
>> and I will also while I'll be traversing
uh the I can actually traverse from the
from the end and just apply yeah so I'll
be
>> the idea of the algo and the plan
itself. So I going to convert this to
array.
>> Mhm. First I will traverse from right to
the left.
>> Mhm.
>> While traversing this one I would add up
to my maximum suffix and map that stores
value and the last index occurrence
which will be essentially the first
index in this case.
>> Um
>> no yes the first yeah the first index in
this case. Uh and then in the end I
would just go from left to right and the
first time I see maximum in my suffix
bigger than value I just swap it with
the uh with the last index of the val of
the maximum value.
>> Yes.
>> Great.
>> Does it sound good? Tell me if it's
okay.
>> Yes. This sounds very reasonable to me.
Yeah. Um, and then again just to
confirm, you said this is what we're
going to get in terms of space and a
runtime, correct?
>> Yep.
>> Oh, and
>> yes.
>> Okay. Awesome. Yeah. Let's code it up
and then we can do a dry run on both of
these examples.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Makes sense. Okay.
>> The idea sounds great to me.
>> Great. Great. Makes sense. Makes sense.
So let's say I don't know, let's put it
as a solve. We have some number. It's
going to be integer.
Then first initial thing I would convert
it to array which is simple conversion I
guess
uh maybe yeah yeah yeah as far as I
don't really remember will it work in
Python or no
>> uh don't stress about it like if you
don't remember the library just write me
like uh in the note what do you want to
convert to and from. So the thing is
that I want to convert this as let's say
this is a number and I want to have in
the end
uh 9 2 3 8 8 86 essentially I can parse
it up on my own. No worries. So I can
make
>> Yeah, it's okay. Assume this this does
it. Honestly I think it just need a
string here but um yeah assume like this
is what it does.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think maybe we can do
this. Yeah, probably. Yeah, I will need
to check Python API, but if it doesn't
work, I can code it up and pass it
myself.
>> Yeah, don't stress about it. Assume
assume this works.
>> Okay. Okay. Makes sense. Makes sense. Uh
then following our plan, I'm starting
from the from the end till the
beginning. So for that I would need my
suffix max uh which is going to be this
one. current maximum which is going to
be
uh the last element
uh
yeah this is for future
I will ask it later so let's say we are
not empty for now
maximum is the last one
and then we also should have our map
not default
just map and we start for index in
reversed range
lengths array
1 2 3 1 exactly.
So uh
as we are going we would say we try to
find our maximum which is going to be
maximum of our array index.
So this is going to be maximum.
Then we are adding or appending value to
our no suffix we cannot append. So for
that reason I actually have to do this
because I I need it in original order as
well. Uh so index is going to be
maximum.
Then we are adding
um
so from the right to left order we are
adding only the first occurrence of the
index. For that reason I will just check
if
uh array
index in map sorry not in map only. In
that case I will add it as a value. So
array index equals index
Yep.
All right. And after this
for loop, we essentially should have
already premputed suffix,
premputed
uh map of our indices and the largest
value. And now we're starting our last
piece of the algo. Uh so we are
traversing from left to right right now.
um
in range
links array.
And now we are checking if our current
value
is less than
yeah it should be less than our suffix
at this index.
In this case we need to swap.
So how do we do that? We find the
right index via map.
So map is going to be our well yeah our
maximum value which is suffix by the
way.
And then we just essentially doing the
following uh
just typical Python swap.
Uh let me know if it makes sense because
otherwise I would need to do it via
temporary variable.
>> No, it's it looks good. No, no, it looks
good.
>> Okay, so after we swap at this point we
should break
and also in the end we need to convert
our array back to number.
So for that uh for that I would first
convert it to string probably. So let's
say string equals
join whatever we have
and then I would actually return int
string.
>> Sounds great. Yeah.
>> Let me now check uh whether it all makes
sense at all. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. [snorts] And I actually have
a question for you because um the map
you populated here, correct? That's like
that's where you use it.
>> This is where where I'm populating it
and I'm using it here.
>> Right here. Okay. Sounds great. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Sounds great. Yeah. Let's do a dry
run. Honestly, pick any example. Maybe
start with something simple like don't
go into like the heavy example if you
want. Just like let's see how it works
here.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. So uh yeah let's
let's run I have three examples to run
in uh
>> Sure.
>> So this one
sorry to run through and then
this one and our heavyweight
uh this guy.
>> Okay.
>> So for the first one uh let's see
uh let's see. So I would straight away I
would just assume that uh this thing
will convert it straight away to my
array.
So it should be this already
and then I would add essentially
indices. So we have it in mind and I
would add suffix
which is
uh
yep and initially suffix is zero
completely
>> and our map
is also empty.
So uh we do start from the rightmost
index to the leftmost and current
maximum for us is uh the last element in
array which is six.
So
yes yes yes it's going to be six and now
we are starting so we can computing the
maximum so far which is six and six
going to be six suffix for this index is
going to be six
great uh then we are finding that our
number six is not an in array yet
>> uh so we are adding it so it's going to
be six current index three.
We move forward. We find out the number
a sorry number three. Uh for number
three the suffix is still going to be oh
sorry the maximum is going to be six. So
we put six here as well. And then we are
adding map. So for value three we have
index two.
Now we are moving eight is going to be
sorry max is going to be eight. Again,
we don't have it here. So, we put eight
one.
And this guy is going to be eight now
because maximum has changed. And the
last one, again, we didn't see this
number yet. So, we put it zero. And
maximum is going to be eight. Now, we're
going from range blah blah. We see array
from left to right. Again, uh current
array number is two. So, it's less than
maximum suffix. So we do apply our algo
and we find right index through the map
of the value of suffix. So we go eight
we find eight it will be index one which
is this guy. Amazing. Now we are just
swapping. So what will happen is this
becomes this this becomes that
and then we break and then we join array
back to 8 236
and then it will be integer. So this
will be the answer. Uh to me this simple
one works.
Uh let me try run the next one.
>> Yeah, if you want to feel free to like
shorten uh the amount of numbers that
you have like it doesn't have to be so
many. Up to you.
>> Yeah, I will shortcut the debugging
process in general because we kind of
make sure most of this is working.
>> Yeah.
>> So we don't waste much time about that
>> on this. Uh so anyway, let's try again.
0 0 0.
So maximum is the last one which is six.
Map is empty.
Okay. Again we are going from right. Uh
we find maximum six. We put six equals 5
and we put here six. Then we go here. We
find eight. We put eight here. And since
it doesn't exist yet, we still put it to
the map. So it's going to be four index.
We move on. Maximum is still eight. So
we put eight. We see that it is in map.
So we skip it.
Uh then we move forward with three. Uh
three is not bigger than eight. So still
eight. We put three equals to
second index. We find out two. Same
thing again. It's still eight. And we
put two equal to index one. And the last
one is nine which is actually greater
than uh eight. So we put updated one
and we put it index zero. Now let's try
to move from left to right. So we see
current value 9 is not less than our
maximum. So we just skip. Next iteration
is going to be uh number two. For number
two, it is less than uh than eight. So
we process and we go into this if
we go find uh index four as uh as this
uh digit we swap two and eight. So this
becomes eight. This becomes two and yeah
the rest is the same. We break convert
to string and this will be the largest
number. So uh does look good uh for now.
>> Yeah. Uh, Andrea, I do have a question
for you. If we just think, again, I
don't think we can do better runtime
wise, but I think we could do better
memory wise. Can you without like
changing the code, I don't want you to
change anything. I just want you to tell
me where you think we could optimize
memory. And I specifically I'm looking
at both of these data structures and I
wonder do you think we could maybe like
drop one of them or just to kind of
optimize the memory? What do you think?
Yep. I guess I guess we can.
>> I guess we can. Uh
>> what would we drop and why?
>> Well, let's think logically and try to
rule out both of them uh one at a time.
So, can we remove suffix in general? Can
we do that? Um, if we're going from
right,
we kind of
let me think through it. Maybe we even
can. I don't know. Uh, so we have number
nine and we need to know that this
number is not the one to change.
Let me let me help you. Let me give you
a hint or a thought.
>> Okay. Sure. Sure.
>> If we were not because you have a map,
right? I really think you need a map,
right? Because you need to know where
you stand and what you're looking at. So
I think if you don't know where you are
and what you're looking at, like I don't
think you can solve this problem. So
let's say let's agree that we need this.
The question is
in the map, if you were not saving
whatever you had in the suffix map, what
else can you be saving as your value in
the map? [snorts]
I might straight.
So actually talking back about the map,
we actually can get rid of it and we
might not even store index and then in
all we can find our value and it will be
of n + n which will be n anyway. So we
can drop map. Let's be honest, it will
be a bit slower average runtime, but
worst case it will be still the same.
But let's not talk about this. Let's
think about
uh our suffix.
>> Mhm.
>> So potentially maybe we can store
index I don't know straight away. Uh
can we?
So if suffix
Yeah, why not? we can store index
straight away and we can just instead of
checking u
the suffix itself we can check like this
let's say
and in this case we can store uh we can
kind of detect when it will be lower or
whatever and then we can update index
instead of maximum so we can but I don't
see how index storing index in suffix
would improve runtime anyhow how oh
sorry uh space complexity anyhow
>> yeah I'll just give you an idea so I
actually think uh you wouldn't need the
suffix map I think what you could store
is your index where you're at right like
right now you're at zero or right now
you're at one
>> y
>> and you could just store the digits
itself right so here you were mapping
them to suffix but you could just map it
to themselves and when you come here you
basically will be comparing to like
exactly where you're at and what's
basically
uh behind you. You will only swap
if the thing ahead of you you can
because you can look at this number,
right? Like you can take eight and
three. You know that you're standing at
one and you know that you're standing at
two and it would only make that swap if
whatever is at two is greater than
whatever is at one. Right? So
what I'm trying to say is that this map
could be mapping. I still think you
absolutely need this map, but I say that
you don't need to flip it through
suffixes. You can just map directly to
the numbers that you're looking at. Do
you see what I mean?
>> Uh let me try to
reverse it back to original example. So
if I see anything bigger than uh current
value. Okay. So in this case,
but I still need to get somehow to
eight, right?
>> Right.
>> I mean, I can straight away maybe swap.
So can I can I just keep swapping up
until it's less?
>> Uh you can only swap once.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That that makes sense.
But I mean um
like technically in the end it can be
counted as a uh single one. So what do I
mean by that is that we can kind of
internally do like propagating it all
all the way down. So what I mean by that
is we first swap this and kind of up
until two is less
No, it doesn't make sense.
>> No, it doesn't make sense. Forget about
what I just said.
>> No, but I think the idea is correct.
Like your algorithm is correct. You can
check though because also,
you know, the largest digit you can have
is nine, right? Like it cannot be
greater than nine, whatever you're
looking at. And then you can just go
from nine all the way to eight and ask
yourself,
is what I'm looking at greater than the
largest digit I've seen so far?
And basically it's um it's two nested
loops but it will still be of n.
Exactly. You cannot do better than of n
or worse than of you shouldn't be doing
worse than of and you will um swap the
digit. I will show you what I meant
afterwards. But overall like the idea of
your algorithm is correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Sorry. I I think I I
don't get uh yet to this. Um I will need
to think through it. Okay. Anyway, uh I
should have asked you before but uh yeah
just for for the audience
>> we talked with Anna before and I already
know I going to have two questions but
in real case you should always ask
whether this is the only single question
you're going to solve or no
>> because yeah you will conclude a lot of
about complexity and time management.
>> Sorry.
>> Yep.
Yeah. All good. So let's carry on and
let's talk about actually I want to give
you a tree question if that's okay.
>> Sure.
>> So um I want to show you and tell me if
you solve this problem before. Maybe you
know it exactly how it goes. But
actually I really want to talk to you
about how to traverse a tree in a zigzag
level order. And I'll show you what I
mean. So let's say we have the stream
and sorry uh basically you can tell that
we have three 9 20 no children on the
left 15 and seven but what I'm asking
you is to take the route as it is and
then go first
left to right so 29 to 9. So, we're
going this way. And then on the next
level, we're actually going to go the
usual way, right? Uh, sorry,
left to right. So, yes, right to left,
left to right. So, however levels we
have, we first start right to left and
then we go left to right.
>> Okay, let me just quickly draw an
example as a tree. So,
>> sure. Mhm.
>> So I can visually Yeah, Google Doc is
not the best probably for
>> Yeah, I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, that's that's that's good. That's
good. So let's say we have two here,
three here, and then we have
I don't know
these two.
And here we have four, five, six, seven,
whatever. Uh it's not balanced as I can
see right so I cannot assume it's
balance.
>> Yeah
>> sure. Uh so zigzag so we we are starting
as one then
oh my god we are starting as what what
just happened sorry we're starting as
one then we go three two and then we go
four five six seven.
>> That's correct.
>> This is the idea. Okay. Uh-huh.
>> Okay. Um, I'm not sure I solved exactly
this question, but something about
zigzaga I remember, but I don't really
remember the solution, so I'm not sure.
Um,
>> it's okay. We'll solve it together.
>> Okay.
Okay. Okay. So, what do I think about
this? Uh, and it's always level wise.
So, if I let's say remove these two and
set them to null, uh, it will be still
one.
3 2 6 7
>> correct. Yeah. Yeah. I don't want to see
nulls like in your answer even though we
see them here, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. We don't need them in answer.
>> I just assume that we don't have any.
Okay. Okay. Makes sense. Makes sense.
Makes sense. Okay.
>> So, since this is sort of level order uh
thingy, so let's assume three and it
always grows to the bottom. So, we're
going to have more nodes in the end than
in the beginning. And we want them to
traverse zigzag
uh level by level. And by level I mean
uh how far the node the nodes on the
current level are from the root. So
nodes on the same level have exactly
same distance to the root essentially
>> um or they don't exist in case of not
full uh tree. Mhm.
>> So to me it feels initial idea to do a
BFS
because uh the natural
way how BFS works that we are going to
work every single time with single row
>> and then we can just maintain some state
variable that will tell us should we go
from right to left or from left to
right.
>> Sure.
>> This is the basic uh approach that I'm
thinking right now. uh the complexity
here would be
of which is where n is number of nodes
space- wise it will be the biggest level
so if in the if in the end of the tree
we have I don't know 10 nodes the the
leaves 10 leaves it'll be over all all
of 10 essentially
>> so this is my general idea for now how
does it feel is it okay or no we should
do better
>> yeah this sounds Can you tell me a
little bit more about uh this variable
that you're going to do? What are you
going to do when you come to a case like
this? How would you
um
like what will this variable exactly be
that's going to tell you what level
you're at? Like how will you know that
you're at that level? It's just going to
be like incremental plus one.
>> Uh no no sorry for variable I was
thinking this variable will uh represent
whether it is reversed or no. So or I
don't know uh it can be right to left
whatever and we starting with right to
left
>> and then uh once I process all the nodes
on current level I switch right to left
to opposite so it will be right to left
uh not right to left essentially after
each of the level and I don't actually
need to maintain which level am I right
now because BFS
uh well it will be sort of uh implicitly
maintained in the way that we are doing
BFS with a bit hack on top that we are
going to process only the number of
nodes we discovered before. So
essentially the way I'm going to do it I
will maintain Q of course essentially Q
will start with one we just visit one
and add it to output then meanwhile we
are visiting one we explored two nodes
right
>> then uh I would be process since I know
there are two nodes I explored before
I'm going to pop only two items from the
queue
>> and while I'm popping two items in the
queue of course I going to add six and
seven at some point So when when I'm at
three uh so let me draw it a bit. So
let's say this is the queue.
>> I'm adding one and I popped one and I
explored two and three.
>> Then I popped three but I remember that
my size was uh two which is
two and three right.
>> Mhm.
>> So once I pop three here and I explored
six and seven. So I will add six and
seven. So in the original BFS I would
actually traverse them but since I know
the size is three I going to do only one
more pop and I will leave my next level
as it is and then next level we proceed
again the same way. So we are going to
pop only two elements and explore. Let's
say these two nodes have two child each.
In this case uh in the end we're going
to have uh four more items popped here
and sorry added here and two ones popped
essentially. This is the idea.
>> Sounds great. Can I just ask you one
more thing? I just want to make sure
let's say this tree makes a lot of
sense, right? Because when we get to the
last level, we kind of see the kids.
>> What if you had four or five here, but
you had nothing
uh on this side? Um how would you go
from three to four five?
And basically,
yeah, you're going to go get this and
then you go this way, right?
Um yeah, how can you like grab those
kits? [snorts]
>> Uh
okay. So um the problem is with ordering
probably.
Yeah, give me
maybe we don't even need to reverse in
this case. Let me think. So yeah, it
will
>> there are many ways to go about it.
Yeah.
>> Uh essentially it will still work. So
let's assume um
we have two three no we have three two
right because we go from right to left.
Yes we have 32.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And then uh
append pop left.
Pop left is the first one that goes. So
first one that came essentially okay let
me add this is the beginning of the
queue and this is the end of the queue
so we don't confuse each other so if I'm
adding uh three and then two
I will add
three and then two this will be my Q
>> because pop left in Python at least
should return the
the first. No. So it should be
essentially this three and two. Yes. And
so we append appends to the right. Uh so
this is append place and this is pop
left place. So this is just to not
confuse myself and then we would pop
left three.
Three doesn't have anything. So we would
just pop it and [snorts]
do whatever. Okay. Uh Q is empty. We
didn't add anything.
And then uh of course we would add it to
answer.
Then when we have two we would explore
and append.
Uh and now we should understand which
direction we should append.
Uh yeah we should keep the variable
actually. Yeah we should keep the
variable.
>> Mhm.
>> So we know which one we add. We add
first right child or left child. That
makes sense.
Yes.
[snorts] Yes. And since
so I need them to start from the
beginning because I don't know what
should be the variable. So initially we
should go from left to right. Then this
one is right to left. Left to right.
>> So right to left is false initially.
If it's false.
Yeah. So I would do with right to left
equals to false initially because the
initial item is still left to right the
root itself. Then we go right to left as
in the example. Uh since we go right to
left.
Yeah. Yes. Yes. So given root I will see
that right to left is false and it means
I need to add them reversed. Uh so like
traversal itself right to left will be
false but I will be adding them exactly
right to left because the next iteration
I going to do is going to be right to
left.
>> Mhm.
>> So I would add first right then left
children which is going to be append uh
three and two.
Uh yes. Then I will switch it to true
again.
>> Mhm.
>> Which means the next case or or in this
case Yeah. The next case I going to add
them is from left to right.
>> Mhm.
Wait a moment.
Will it work? It wouldn't work.
It will not work.
So I think there is a bit better idea.
There is a bit better idea. We don't
care about variable at all up until we
populate uh whole level. So let's not
care about variable completely.
We just do regular BFS from left to
right all the time.
>> We still do level order traversal in a
sense. So every single time uh we are
going to have result as a single line or
single level.
That's it. It will be our exactly
complexity of uh uh max level of the
space complexity.
>> And while we have this thing then we
will just use variable and then we will
just either do it from the end or from
the left from the right side or from the
left side
>> and then we will just keep traversing
same way from left to right all the
time. So all like we start BFS we
process these two uh nodes and we will
add these two nodes from left to right
again same thing here we start with this
from left to right from left to right
but in the end uh we are going to have
resulting array from left to right which
we can just decide either we're going
from right to left or from left to right
deciding or based on this variable that
we're going to be swapping essentially
this idea
>> uh
I guess it should talk at least this
this is my gut feeling for now.
>> Yeah. Um this makes sense to me and
honestly like you got the idea correctly
like you literally go level by level and
then you decide to reverse it or not to
reverse it. Uh then again there are many
levers right like you can you can count
you can check the length. Uh but yeah
let's just like one more time agree what
is the runtime and space complexity of
what you're proposing.
>> Okay
>> what would it be? So runtime we always
need to traverse all the nodes. So it
will be
uh n of nodes and this will be all one
for the this is time complexity for the
space complexity it's going to be
of
number of leaves.
This will be the space complexity like
or maybe maximum number of leaves what
but it will be anyway maximum. So well
yes yes yes. So this is the maximum
number of list is special complexity. So
the y the end line essentially.
>> Yeah this sounds great. Yeah let's code
it up and then maybe we can do like a
simple dry run.
>> Okay. Sure sure makes sense. Uh all
right. All right. So how would start? We
have uh
>> yeah assume I give you a root. I can
give you a signature if you want but
assume you're giving the root.
>> Okay.
>> And the root and the the tree node has
value left and right.
>> If you want I can drop that for you as
well. Yeah.
>> I think I think yeah we we've all solved
like thousands of these questions and uh
good. Uh so I would assume there is some
global variable which is result
that we are going to return. So yeah,
let me maybe put it. Okay, let me put it
this way. So this is going to be just
task or whatever. And here we're going
to maintain result [snorts]
which is the resulting scene. We're
going to return essentially this two
dimensional array. Mhm.
>> We're going to have Q which is D Q with
our root
and then
uh we are doing the following.
So
yeah we don't have visited set because
we cannot get the same nodes uh I guess
but [snorts] yeah yeah we cannot.
So then I would do while length of Q is
still while we have something in the
queue we remember the size um
and then we also keep maintaining uh
or let's do it left to right initially
let's do it this it feels more natural
to me. Uh so initially this is our root
and for root we traverse left to right
because next one should be right to
left.
>> Mhm. So now we are doing the following.
We are traversing uh and
for
number of times of size
we're essentially going to pop node. Uh
Q pop left the first one we got. Then if
node left
um
if we have node left we would do q
append node left
value. No not value.
I have node right
node right.
And now still we want and we want to
append all this time we have some array
like I don't know
level or whatever
>> this is the array and whatever we append
we do level append node value
>> this will be our scene that we are going
to store in as a second dimension in
result array. So we this is going to
have just a root.
So once we processed everything then we
decide
uh if
yeah we would need to reverse if if it's
not left to right
I would assume we can do the following.
You can do or does Python has this like
level reverse?
>> Uh I'm not sure Python has this but I
can just do it then.
>> Yeah. Or you can do this thing the
double colon minus one. Do you remember
that one?
This one.
>> Oh yes yes yes.
>> Up to you. But reversed also works.
>> I've seen it. Never used it.
[laughter] It's actually minus one, by
the way. It's minus one because you're
telling it to Yeah, it's just like a
code. Mhm. That's right.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
Uh, okay. So, I guess I need to also
reassign it probably.
>> Nice.
>> And so then we are just result append
this level array and then we reassign in
level to be empty.
Oh, it will be reassigned anyway
upstairs. Whatever.
>> At some point we will just
return
result.
>> Now let me just dry check it quickly.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. Pick like a small
>> result Q root. Sorry [snorts] left to
right. True.
And we also need to reset our left to
[snorts] right
to not forget this. Now size Q level is
our array
and this size. Cool. Pop left.
Working with values. Great. [snorts]
Working with notes. Great.
Yeah, essentially let me dry run these
two examples.
Uh so first one this one.
So we would have left uh to right equals
true initially. This is our Q
and this is our level.
Let's start. First we have one in the
queue. Uh size is going to be one. So we
are going to do okay let me put size is
one. Uh we are going to do
yeah only single pop. So we're popping
one. We put it to level. Uh just here uh
we do have two nodes. So we append first
left then right. So we append two.
Uh since it's Q let me be careful. So
this is pop left and this is append. So
in this case we are appending two and
then we are appending three. Cool.
Since it's size kind of decreased to
zero in for loop we checking it's not
left to right. No it is left to right.
So we don't reverse anything. Uh we
reversing left to right again. uh back
to false
at the moment and then we are appending
result of our level to result. So
essentially result is going to be one.
Cool.
Then we are iterating again because Q is
not empty. We're going to go size three
two sorry size two. And then we're going
pop left which is
uh we are popping two
and with node two we have four and five.
So we are adding
four and five.
That's it. Then we pop
third. Of course we're adding this guy
to our level which got reassigned. So
we're adding it too.
Now we're popping again third one and
three doesn't [snorts] uh explore any
more nodes. So we're just appending it
to the level again. And after that we
kind of move out from this uh from this
for loop. We're checking if it's not
left to right which it is not. We're
reversing. So our level is going to be
32 instead of 2 three.
And then
and then we are going to be appending it
to our level. Oh sorry to our result
and this is going to be true again.
Amazing. Now we have four. Four is going
to be just popped uh size is going to be
two again. Uh so four is going to be
popped and appended here. And five is
going to be popped and appended here.
Now we have empty Q by the way and still
it's
uh this one is going to be false because
it is left to right and we are assigning
it back appending this fox here.
So 1 3 2 4 5 amazing next example.
Uh yeah in the end we return it. Okay
next example is going to be this one. So
essentially the same we can do a bit of
shortcut. Uh so
for 32 it it will be exactly the same
result. And now let's just do the last
level of
uh how we would explore it. Or maybe
yeah maybe let's start with one. So
we're going to have
uh initially
two and three.
Yes. Then we pop two.
Append it to level. We don't find
anything. So we don't append anything.
Then we pop three. We found six seven.
Uh sorry 67. And we put three here.
Initially our left to right was true
then now it's false so we reverse
and we append it
again and 67 now 67 how it should be uh
we're again popping everything and
essentially we would put it here since
left to right wait true false true then
it's going to be true at that at that
point
So we don't reverse and we just adding
it to the result. To me it makes sense.
It should work.
>> Uh sounds great. Yeah. Let's cut it
here. Like let's take off our
interviewer's hats. Um blah blah blah.
Okay. You have some water. But my first
question to you is like how do you think
you did?
>> Uh well I think I did average kind of
okay. Uh
the only thing that I didn't get the
feedback about sorry follow up about the
space complexity which is I just I just
couldn't I just couldn't grasp this like
it my brain just stuck at the moment and
I didn't know because
>> okay yeah I think it's a part of being
nervous and you just can't think
straight
uh but like don't worry about the space
how do you think like in general how do
you think was your code like were you
super lost? Were you super confused like
what the is going on or do you
think you kind of had a good grasp on
like how to move through the through the
problems?
>> No, honestly. Okay, it might sound a bit
cocky, but I think I would get higher
for sure after this interview. But uh
talking about my experience, at some
point I got lost with this zigzag
because I started messing up this uh
variable and I started thinking deeply
about different examples that if I just
try to not work with the level as a line
but try to
try to make a decision how do I append.
So I maybe I will append you know. So I
was thinking about this so to to change
the order of appending
>> based on this variable left to right. So
something like this I I was thinking to
do
>> and it got me so deep in different edge
cases and I got at some point stuck and
lost and then I just stopped myself and
thought that okay we anyway have worst
case that we have this level let's do it
as simple as possible and then it kind
of
>> got progressed uh easy because this is
the pattern kind of I I can blindly
quote any time so I did it so many times
but just this in initial intuition
>> uh like while I just got the problem and
this first five 10 minutes up until I
really have mental model and have an
idea of how do I proceed these are kind
of hard but once I have the idea coding
part is
>> yeah and listen you've never seen these
problems before right I mean honestly
for somebody who's never I don't know
maybe you saw them like years ago you
forgot you did really really well
>> oh thank you uh so this one first
problem I never solved it
>> uh second problem probably I have solved
it but years ago like
>> it doesn't matter. Yeah. [snorts]
>> Okay. I want to give you feedback
because again I know people are going to
be watching this and they can just
listen in but I want you to do really
well in your interview. So again my
verdict is I will pass you for L4 but
again I just want to tell you because
from what my experience and from how I
approach my interviews there are a
couple things you can be doing better.
And again, I am leveling you for a
senior engineer, right?
>> For L4, I think you did really, really
well.
>> Um, but I want to kind of tell you like
what can be better for a senior
engineer. So,
>> let's dive in. First of all, I want to
tell you this is a little bit of smell.
>> What can you do about this?
Tell me
>> uh
>> these three things together.
Oh, well, I can return straight away
from this place probably.
>> That's right. Please write it down.
>> Uh, yeah, sure.
>> And I don't I don't want to see this
variable either. So, you can do it
together. Yeah. Mhm.
>> Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, that makes
sense. That makes sense.
>> Yeah, it's okay. You know, in the
interview, you just want to like write and but just like breaks in
general, try not to do that. I
understand. Also, if you write it, just
say it. say. So, I know it's smelly. I
know it's bad. Like, a better approach
is blah blah blah. Just say something.
Okay.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Uh, one thing, I think you were also a
little bit nervous when we're doing this
problem. You didn't really ask me
clarifying questions. You came back to
it afterwards and you asked me, can it
be a zero? Right? Like some point like
after you like 20 minutes into it, you
asked me, can it be a zero? Can it be
negative? Right? See, that was also a
valid question.
>> Uh, yeah. And the truth is
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's a bad Oh my
god. Yes. Yes. Yes. I I was I was about
to ask, but then I started nervous.
Forgot about this. That's why.
>> That's right.
>> Uh, okay. So, sorry it's a little bit
loud here because of the truck, but my
point is, so before you write anything,
I know you're just like eager to kind of
think through, stop for a second,
breathe out, just like truly catch a
break and ask yourself,
what's my input? Like, this input,
frankly, could have been a string. Like,
you know, like you didn't ask me.
And if it was a string, then you
wouldn't need to do this right?
Um yes
>> I also don't I've seen a lot of people
get like oh my god can it be like a wild
character like don't ask me the stupid like I told you it's a number right
okay so don't get like spend 10 minutes
asking me about validation of input but
ask questions that really matter like
honestly if this was a negative number
this would have been like a very
different story right
>> yeah it will fail probably
>> yeah so just take a moment like truly
breathe out and think what matters in
this problem right Like and in the video
that I sent you, like they really tell
you like for example ask if you have an
array, is it sorted? Um do we have
strings? Do we have integers? Is it
mixed? Blah blah blah. Okay, I do want
to say something that you were doing
really really great and I hope you don't
stop doing it. You just really think out
loud and it is a skill, right? This is
not a skill of solving lit code
problems. pretty much like your grandma
can solve a lit code problem, but the
grandma cannot be hired because she has
to come in and for 45 minutes she has to
talk and solve. It's two things you have
to do at the same time and this is
mentally and cognitively very very hard.
And I think you did really well. It is
hard to code it up, think it through,
get lost, make mistakes, and keep
talking. Please do not change that. I
want to tell you something that I do
myself that I hope will just help you
when you move forward. So after I've
explained what I want to do. I stop and
I do this. I put actually sometimes I'm
so lazy I just write n which I know is
not correct. So do your own way write of
n
what you wrote here. Sorry. Um and then
same thing here. So before you write
code, I tell my interviewer what this is
going to be and then I ask them
what do you think? How does that sound
to you? Right? So before I write any
code, I know we're under gun to do so,
but my my approach is that I tell them
like this is my idea. This is how much
it's going to cost time and space
complexity. This what do you think?
Because
the thing is that with this map, I will
show you the clean solution. Again, this
is somebody who spent maybe three hours
optimizing it. So,
>> yep.
>> I am not telling you like you your
approach sucks or you're stupid because
again all I was saying is that you can
just save what you're saving like save
on what you're saving. You don't need
the suffixes. You can just save the
numbers and you can just do this
reversal from nine. Anyway, you're going
to look at the solution. You will
understand what I mean.
>> But the thing is that you jumped right
after this. He didn't ask me and I could
have told you you don't need to do this
again. I don't know if you would have
come up with a different solution right
off the bat and at the end I would have
told you okay it just go write a
brute force like write something like I
need you to write code.
>> So but my trick is that after you've
done this just ask them do you think
there is a better solution? Do you think
this works for you? And then after they
give you a verbal yes, then you write
your code because otherwise I could have
helped you here, but you just went
straight.
Um, and then I think actually you were
validating your plan really well when we
were on this problem, right? When we
were in the tree, you were very verbal
with me and you were like, "Hey, what do
you think?" You asked me, right? Like,
"What do you think? Can we do better or
whatever?" Like you somehow like I think
you were not as nervous here anymore.
and you were way more in touch with me,
which was great because at the end of
the day, I'm not like a Like, I
want you to do well, but if you don't
ask me anything, then I can't help you.
>> Makes sense.
>> Um,
in general, I think this is basically
all the feedback I have for you. Uh,
there was something else
about Oh, okay. I will show you. There
is a trick to do this a little bit nicer
with like you kind of have to know this
mathematical tricks about how many nodes
you have. But I also do want to tell you
something else. When you are writing out
space complexity, listen, these are the
same things, don't you think?
>> Uh, sorry. Where do I point? Uh,
>> leaves and nodes. Do you see when I'm
highlighting it here?
[sighs]
>> Um,
think about it.
Well, not necessarily the same, right?
If you have huge height,
but it will be much less. Yeah, it will
be like the number of leaves would be a
majority of the nodes. That's true.
That's true.
>> Yeah. You will never need to touch more
than you have, right? You will only
touch every single thing once. If you
don't have it, great. You just don't
have it.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> Um,
and in general, I actually also want to
tell you maybe one thing.
>> Try to simplify when you do dry run. Try
to simplify your cases. Watch the clock
a little bit.
>> Okay?
>> Because again, I was telling you like
this number is too big. Like don't take
this big number. You're just gonna like
waste time like checking this like three
and eight like two times. Don't do it.
like just pick a clear
um distinct example that shows your
point
and just just keep it short like just
show that it works. Keep the dry run a
little bit faster.
>> Okay, makes sense. Makes sense.
>> Don't lose yourself because ultimately
you're wasting time on the follow-up.
>> Makes sense.
>> If we're out of time, I cannot give you
a follow-up.
>> Makes sense. Makes sense. Yep. So when
you pick an example, right, like maybe
you were explaining your algorithm on
this, like I loved it, but then when
you're doing a dry run, say like, hey,
is it okay if I just keep take like a
smaller example or take a cleaner leaner
case?
>> Okay.
>> So that's kind of what I have for you
today.
>> Okay. What's your cool?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I got the feedback.
Definitely I will be I'll still be
prepping, right? Uh so
yeah it's great to to have the feedback
so I I know some points to focus on um
especially about clarification because
>> you know I'm doing this le code marathon
for like past week and in lead code
right
>> you don't have to clarify anything
because you know they they put the
constraints you just go and check okay
can be negative and you see it's like
less than or equal
>> or the test fails and that's how you
know right
>> uh yeah yeah yeah well I I don't
actually run it before I debugged did a
dry run. So, I'm following approach. I'm
trying to follow. It's hard and requires
discipline and cognitive effort, but
still I'm trying to do this.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um yeah, it was nice actually. Amazing
problems. Uh this one, could you pass me
the
>> I will I'll send you both the problem
and my solution and feel free to share
them with people as well.
>> Oh, sure. Sure. I will.
>> If you can clean it up, please share
like a cleaner solution as well. Uh but
then again, remember that this people
spent hours doing that. So what you did
never having seen this problem before is
much more relevable than people who
spent hours who knows with charge
without charge doing that.
>> Uh but maybe there's something you can
learn from them as well.
>> Sure.
>> Just like in terms of cleaner code
cleaner just exits this type of stuff.
And then again, listen, it's not a sin
if you do it. But just say that you know
you can do better because I if you don't
tell me then like okay this truck this
bro just rides breaks everywhere like at
this level you should know that this is
not great. Okay. And you can say so.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Yeah. That makes
sense. That I didn't even think it was
just Yeah. I didn't even think about
that. [laughter] I was like break and I
return. Yeah. That's it.
>> It's okay. like you just want to show
how it works, but you can do better.
Just like verbally say like I know it's
a smell and try to like clean it up.
>> All right. Uh so thank you. It was Anna,
senior engineer from
uh please check the description and
follow her in stack uh Substack, I'm
sorry. Follow her [laughter] on
Substack.
>> Follow me on Stack Overflow.
>> Yeah. And on Stack Over overflow as
well. Yeah. because uh if you're
especially if you're finding something
for interview uh Anna Anna is a beast in
behavioral. So if you need to have some
tips about behavioral you definitely
should go and read
>> articles. So
>> yep
>> and do mocks. We can do another mock
with you. [laughter]
>> Yes, at some point at some point we will
need to do a mock for sure because I I
suck at behavioral much more than in
lead code.
All right,
>> go rest. Good job today. I will send you
the solutions. Please share them with
people as well. And then hopefully we'll
do another mock.
>> Thank you. Yeah, thank you. It was a
nice time. Thank you so much and see
you.
>> See you next time. Bye.